[Musique]
les enfants boss
patron wind & north je voudrais vous
demander une petite permission dis-moi
nounours
est ce que demain après midi je pourrais
emmener nicolas et pimprenelle à la
foire à la fois les patrons à la grande
fête
là où il ya des manèges d'agde leur
nounours mais tu l'aies surveillera bien
et ils demanderont la permission avant à
leurs parents oui oui merci je vous
embrasse
et jetés sans vite leur annoncer la
bonne nouvelle l'eau ou le sol pom pom
pom pom pom pom pom
il en invitant notre mémoire ce soir ça
elle n'est pas pressée à la des amis je
vous apporte une grande nouvelle
vraiment annonce vraiment nenê vous ne
me demandez pas ce que ce mardi le nom
la honte elle demande comment si vos
parents sont d'accord nous allons à la
fin
[Musique]
on va s'amuser
c'est la troupe est qu on attend
quand je l'entends je suis content
c'est la fête on va s'amuser
nounours va nous accompagner
on montrera ce n'est le plus joli manège
remonter sur les chevaux de bois
on ira jouer aux anneaux
on regardera les autos
on rencontrera des amis
qui sommes nous aurons deux aussi nous
nous irons chercher de grogne aussi
c'est que nous n'oserons acheter des
petits nous garde
approchant sera fatigué
on va se reposer
tous les jours après la dînette
on y habitait ce congé
[Musique]
tu es magnifique mineurs je veux être
très élégant pourra lui à la fin allons
vite au lui les enfants il est
avisé demain
à quelle heure vient nous chercher je
viendrai vers 3 heures alors rendez-vous
à 3 gère la nuit nous notons une annonce
à demain à 2011 auront
beau 2
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors chers patrons oliva on sent drôle
mais oui nounours ou lolo fait que tu
aies chic n'est ce pas c'est pour aller
à la fin demain et bien en route
bonne nuit les enfants patron ne vous
fatiguez pas bonne nuit les enfants
embrasser bien forte votre famille
faites votre toilette et n'oubliez pas
de vous laver les dents est fait pour
où
[Musique]
e
[Applaudissements]
en